jamais entendu le dicton jamais volé la banque en
face d'un restaurant a le meilleur beignet
voir trois comtés ce n'est pas une chose
ce mec non ce n'est pas je me remets du
même bébé quand il ne dit pas que c'est un
moi c'est pareil allez tout le monde s'asseoir
sur le  étage
oh allez
combien tu penses 40 millions 40
millions de dollars mais j'ai de mauvaises nouvelles pour
toi qu'est-ce qu'un badge dans ta
main d dit l'officier Michael stigman non
Bobby beans était papa et ton garçon colle un
travail le saviez-vous  il était dans
les forces spéciales ta banane mince nous sommes
trop longs salut au compte de trois nous allons nous
laisser partir un deux trois chéri
fais de lui un je pourrai te faire confiance
la banque était une configuration que nous devons
comprendre  dont l'argent qui était bien aimé
nous travaillons ensemble non pas comme ce qui
était tu sais comme nous travaillons dans le
même masini ensemble dans le même indicatif
régional encore une fois
arnaqué la CIA où est l'argent ce
n'est pas là-bas je garantis  vous que
[ __ ] c'est un moyen de sortir de dessin animé il
avait 24 heures pour br  ing me the Monsignor
to Joker to the theme yeah so funny
quel est ton plan j'ai un plan je veux dire je suis
capable de prendre mon relais capable
je dis juste que tu ne m'as pas dit sur
quoi je travaille  ouais merde ne fais pas
ton plan personne ne s'attendait à ce que tu
aurais vu ton visage bien sûr que tu peux faire confiance à
ce gars s'ils étaient oh oui sympa de faire
ma famille aujourd'hui ils veulent en quelque sorte
me dire que je comprends le domaine
ce que je t'ai fait  en plus de tirer, la
récréation est terminée si je t'ai correctement
incité plus que tu ne le sais
fais pleuvoir tu es mon peuple il y a un code
tu te bats pour le gars qui se bat
ensuite
donne moi les clés que tu veux réunir
Oh mon fils appelle donne moi les clés vu
ça  la lune arrive c'est correct donne moi
les clés